"Avatar 2" plunges moviegoers back into the
beautifully-realized world of Pandora, but
did James Cameron forget to flesh out the
film's heroine?
Neytiri, we hardly know you.
In terms of its visuals, 2009's "Avatar" remains
in a class all its own.
It revolutionized 3D in Hollywood for several
years, to the point where you practically
couldn't see any movie in a theater without
it getting a rushed 3D treatment.
When it comes to criticizing "Avatar," most
people take issue with the story itself.
Drawing comparisons to "FernGully: The Last
Rainforest" and "Pocahontas," "Avatar" has
your typical white savior story of a marine,
Jake Sully, who's given a new body via an avatar.
He then assimilates into Na'vi culture, and
while he was initially on the side of humanity,
he soon switches over to the indigenous Na'vi,
realizing they shouldn't have their way of
life upended due to colonization.
And who helps him along that journey but his
soon-to-be wife, Neytiri.
Neytiri may be a secondary protagonist, but
in "Avatar," she has a worthwhile arc all
her own.
She brings Jake into her tribe, but turns
her back on him once she realizes he was acting
as a spy the whole time.
After he proves his intentions are pure, she
comes back around and falls in love with him
all over again.
Her character arc is one of acceptance and
willingness to trust.
It's just a shame she isn't given more to
do in the latest installment of the franchise
— "Avatar: The Way of Water."
Neytiri is a fierce warrior — that much
is evident from the film's opening sequences.
Whether hunting for food for her family or
taking down a supply chain from the Sky People,
Neytiri has the skill and bravery to get the
job done.
It's just a shame we never really get a chance
to see her put her skills in action more in
"The Way of Water."
After Jake and Neytiri's children are put
in harm's way by the resurrected avatar body
of Colonel Quaritch, Jake realizes that he
can't endanger his loved ones over this war.
As a result, they decide to move away to be
with another clan while someone else takes
Jake's place.
Neytiri's against it, but eventually, she
relents and agrees to go for the betterment
of her family.
"I need you with me."
From that point forward, Neytiri remains stagnant.
She loves her family, and it's clear she would
do anything to keep them safe.
She also wants to be a warrior, but there's
too much story going on for everyone else,
where it feels like Neytiri gets pushed to
the side to do anything interesting with either
of those ideas.
In "The Way of Water," Neytiri pretty much
exists to react to her kids in peril, forfeiting
any potential for growth and instead being
relegated to a series of reactions.
"This is our home!"
One reason why it feels Neytiri is so thinly
written could probably be attributed to there
being an abundance of characters for "The
Way of Water" to focus on.
In addition to bringing back Jake and Neytiri,
they now have four children to care for.
This is in addition to Spider, who has a tendency
to follow the family around in whatever they do.
And that's not even getting into the new members
of the Metkayina clan.
There's simply too much going on, and other
new characters get a chance at the limelight,
forcing Neytiri into the shadows.
It's a shame, because there's something potentially
interesting about Neytiri wanting to juggle
her desire to be a warrior while protecting
her family.
Based on recent reports, James Cameron has
an entire script of Jake and Neytiri's time
as warriors, which at least sounds like something
that would give Neytiri the development she
so desperately deserves.
But the movie we got completely sidelines
her, to the point we don't even see her for
vast stretches of time.
By the end of the film, we know just as much
about Neytiri as at the beginning of the film.
She loves her family, and she'll kill to protect
them.
But there's no forward growth.
Then again, if Cameron manages to get up to
"Avatar 7," there will be ample opportunities
to give Neytiri the character arc she deserves.